[Musique]
je peux comprendre c'était il ya un an
le 30 avril 2019 à green bay une
fillette de 7 ans connu de la dpj décédé
après avoir subi de mauvais traitements
un drame qui a fortement secoué le
québec cdj faux gras des recommandations
pour éviter qu'un cas similaires se
reproduisent le gouvernement s'engage
alors à faire la lumière sur l'événement
et à réformer la dpj la direction de la
protection de la jeunesse
non seulement en estrie mais partout au
québec pour avoir toute l'information
nécessaire pour nous assurer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé nous
assurer surtout que ça ne se reproduise
plus pourtant un an plus tard les choses
ont bien peu changé à la dpj aps
c'est du moins ce que dit ce travailleur
social de la dpj estrie qui veut garder
l'anonymat par peur de représailles de
leurs enfants sur la liste d'attentes
présentement qui sont en danger
effectivement donc on n'est pas à l'abri
par exemple d'un autre comme celui de la
fillette de green bay ou de la fratrie
qu'on a connu en mars dernier du tout du
tout inquiétant
même son de cloche de la part de
l'alliance du personnel professionnel et
technique de la santé et des services
sociaux qui représentent la majorité des
travailleurs la dpj seulement 10 % des
gens considèrent que les conditions se
sont améliorées à la dpj 50 %
considèrent que ce se sont détériorées
40% disent c'est à peu près pareil fait
qu est ce qu on a vraiment une
amélioration c'est difficile à croire
avec ces chiffres le problème en serait
un de conditions de travail difficiles
dans le contexte actuel d'attirer et de
retenir les travailleurs pain ou si
longtemps qu'ils ne vont pas mettre en
place des choses pour inciter les gens
des choses concrètes salaires conditions
de travail
encadrement soutien à long terme aux
gens pour venir travailler à la dpj
nerpa personne va vouloir venir
il s'enlise depuis écoutez ça remonte à
plus longtemps que la petite fille
pourtant le ministre délégué à la santé
lionel carmant considère que de grandes
améliorations ont été apportées au
réseau de la dpj
c'est quand même 600 intervenants qu'on
a recrutés à travers le québec depuis
avril depuis le dernier budget depuis
l'investissement de 65 millions dont je
vous parlais bien qu'il concède ne pas
pouvoir assurer que tel drame ne se
reproduise
il croit que les conditions des
travailleurs sont sur la bonne voie
cette chose là c'était un peu pâle on ne
peut pas tout prévenir le risque zéro
n'existe pas mais nous ce qu'on veut
faire c'est vraiment mettre des
conditions de travail où il chaque
employé de la dpj va pouvoir s'épanouir
pleinement dans sap dans sa fonction va
avoir les meilleures conditions de
travail pour travailler et surtout
redonner aux enfants à nos enfants tous
les droits auxquels ils ont droit pour
vous
pour les employés de la dpj ces
changements devront se faire rapidement
parce qu'ils sont nombreux à vouloir
quitter le service j'aime suffisamment
mon travail pour dire que j'en garde de
l'espoir mais je sais pas pour combien
pas parce que là j'en suis vraiment me
demander si ma vie personnelle ma
sécurité valent vraiment ce travail là
sur une grande réflexion j'ai déjà
appliquée ailleurs d'un réseau ni le sus
de l'estrie chuss ni la commission
lorrain n'a souhaité nous accorder
d'entrevue ici fanny lachance packet
radio canada sherbrooke